Very,
very nice to be here.
I probably met maybe 60 of you in that hallway there.
So already you feel like family or at least you made me feel very comfortable
that and the free food out there because I had those chips with vinegar.
I love the whole place.
I might apply for a job here with that and I bet it would be a lot less worth
than what I'm the stupid thing I'm doing now,
you know?
Um,
so um,
I've been asked to speak to you and we discussed what would be a good topic.
I always like a topic that people relate to.
All right.
And I'm assuming that we have a crowd of shark tank fans based on what I heard
that,
well,
I want to thank you for my job because we didn't have good seasons by this
point.
We were going to be asked in season one and two.
And so if particularly for the people who are watching early,
you saved our ass or I'd be out the,
okay,
now what do I do?
You know?
So it all worked out very nicely.
As you know,
I'm,
I'm going to talk to you about three things,
like three sections to it,
only a little bit of everything.
You're going to like one of them,
right?
Uh,
I'm going to tell you my rags to riches story because the people organizing the
event wanted me to spend five,
10 minutes on that.
Then I'm going to talk about the entrepreneurs I'm working with and I've even
met a couple of people already today who knows.
Some of my entrepreneurs are friends with them,
so that was kind of Nice.
And so I won't say anything bad about them even though I was going to dish them
like crazy.
And then I'm gonna follow it up with like a little dessert behind the scenes
photos I dragged up from behind the scenes of shark tank.
So you know,
what really goes on and I call that section of it.
What are the sharks really like versus the personas we tried to put forth their,
well,
what would being coached to be on a show versus what we actually are.
Okay.
All right.
So I'll start with the rags to riches story as it pertains to what I wound up
doing for my life work,
which was being a real estate broker here in New York City.
And I really had a very,
very good luck as a child to enormously lucky breaks.
I had two good parents and anybody who's got one good parent.
As you get older,
they get better and better.
In fact,
I don't even know what my mother and father were as good as I'm going to tell
you they were.
But as I get older,
as we all do,
he started to appreciate any advantage you had as a child.
So I had a mom and I'll show you the picture of our family minus one child.
We had 10 kids.
We had six girls,
four boys.
We lived in a little town,
which I'm sure you've heard of Edgewater,
New Jersey,
right across the river when we were there,
every man in town,
except my father was employed by three of large,
three,
one of three factories there.
I actually thought our family was like the Kennedys,
uh,
because my father put a suit on every day to go to work in Trenton,
New Jersey.
And somehow because every other man was in our factory uniform,
except my dad,
I really,
I was like a snob.
Okay.
And my dad actually was a printing press foreman,
uh,
when printing was a big deal before that disappeared,
for many various factories all through our childhood in Trenton,
New Jersey,
typically.
Anyway,
my mother was a powerhouse in my family,
not my dad.
My mom was a phenomenal motivator.
She's probably the most organized person I've ever met in my life.
And I've met so many organized people.
Uh,
my mom would decide on the birth of each child exactly what she thought that
child's gift was.
So she had announced it the day she brought the baby home from holy name
hospital.
We were devout Catholics in our family,
and that's why I haven't been to church since
she overdid that one.
But I remember distinctly when she brought my brother,
uh,
Tommy home and Tommy is the,
the middle row.
Uh,
would it be to your left?
Okay.
With the longish hair.
And she had Tommy as an infant in her arms.
I can remember it was like it was yesterday.
And she said,
look at your brother Thomas.
He's going to be a magnificent dancer.
And we were like,
oh,
I remember me thinking,
Oh,
it dancer in the family.
Cool.
We don't have one of those yet.
And what did my mom base that prediction on?
She saw that Tommy had fat,
juicy legs kicking like hell.
And that was her prediction.
So what happened to my brother Thomas,
who now we called t,
she grew up to be a ballet dancer for Alvin Alley Dance Theater.
And he used to say when he came in to the house after he was long out of the
house and doing the ballet,
he used to say,
the truth is,
I can't really dance.
But mom somehow convinced me I could for me.
She said I had a wonderful imagination.
That was my function in the household.
Just like Tommy's function was to dance.
So my function was to entertain the other kids.
So if it was a rainy day,
I was the person assigned to bring the kids down in the basement and putting on
a Broadway show.
If it was a sunny day,
my mother would make up some kind of shit,
throw it at me as an idea,
like,
why don't you go in the back yard and opened a rock store,
Barbara in and I go like a rock star.
When some rockstars go with your imagination,
you'll figure it out.
And you know what I found?
I could sell rocks as long as you stapled them and white paper and staple the
corners.
Nobody could see which rock they are getting.
People pay for that.
The kids.
All right.
And so our family went.
It was like growing up in a small town.
We had six girls in the girls room,
four boys in the boys' room.
And My mother and father produced all those kids from the living room couch.
My mother's other great gift where she was a phenomenal organizer.
We had the messiest house,
as you could imagine with that many kids.
We have the biggest family,
but we also have the cleanest house when my mother cracked her mental whip on
us.
Right.
And the key to her organizational skill,
which I later learned and building a big brokerage business was she created a
system that's a list,
a system for anything.
She had to do more than twice.
So for example,
we had to sock drawers in the kitchen in our little kitchen and she converted
them to,
pardon me,
bread drawers built in.
That was common then.
And she converted them to to sock drawers.
All the boys socks or the upper drawer,
all navy blue,
all one size.
All the girls were white,
So when you get 10 kids out to school in the morning,
we have to do is grab any socks,
you white and go out the door as long as you remember which store.
And the only kid in my family that got mixed up was of course my brother Tommy.
He went out the white side.
No,
Tommy come back.
So that's how our family when usually organized,
um,
my mother totally iron clad control of every one of her kids.
And you didn't dare not walk the straight and narrow.
My father's job was to be my mother's 11th child and he was totally in shale.
He was totally in charge of other than working during the day of a printing
press foreman and we were in washing trucks for ups at night on weekends.
He did not work.
And our weekends,
his job was to play with his children and we couldn't have gotten a better
playmate.
My Dad had probably the mental maturity level when he was out in the yard of
maybe an eight year old and he did dangerous things with us all the time.
And what do you like more as a kid and something you shouldn't be doing.
And even we knew we shouldn't be doing it but he didn't.
So for example,
if it was a snowy day and we got to stay home from school and he couldn't get up
that oxen hill out of Edgewater,
what would he do?
He would take all of his kids and has many as he could fit in the whole
neighborhood,
put them on the long wooden ladder that ran down our side yard and he'd shove us
down the hill.
He'd hop on the last rung.
We'd go over that retaining wall and into oncoming traffic
when every other kid in town got to go to the automatic car wash and the uptown
above our house,
uh,
all the kids read it.
It's an automatic,
it washes it's automatic.
They had nothing on my dad.
We went up and the little subtle difference that made all the difference was
right before we went in.
We were wondering why did we have to wear pajamas?
He made us wear our pajamas,
right as we went through the car wash,
said,
quick roll down the windows.
So he had this bizarre sense of fun.
And ironically,
when we all get together for weddings,
Christenings,
funerals,
whatever today,
uh,
what did we talk about?
The 12 loads of wash.
My mother hung on the line every other day.
The three meals she put on the table every day.
So we could all eat the clean house.
No,
we don't even mention my mother.
All we do is sit around and say,
Hey,
remember the time dad was at the lake and they had the Hillstone hail storm and
they told us to keep under the water and stay dry?
Ya.
Yeah.
It wasn't that fun.
My mother gets no credit and you know what I've learned?
I've learned that kids don't remember the extravagant vacations.
They'd all becomes a blur later on with children.
Really treasured most is something silly.
And so I had that wonderful role model and my dad of being ridiculous,
and I use that to,
to build my business.
So between my mother's ability to pick out the talent in someone and create
motivation to make them be their best,
what a gift that is to breathe in and out with a woman who did that as a matter
of course,
and her ability to organize any mess and my dad's ability to let it all go,
who gives a damn and have a good time.
I had a lot of different models to choose from and so I was really perfectly
poised to be an entrepreneur.
If you think of him,
I nine siblings as I mentioned at a wall,
my siblings,
only one is not self employed.
Everybody went into business for themselves.
I credit my father entirely with that decision because he hated every bossy ever
worked for if he came home from work at five or four o'clock instead of six
o'clock the usual time when we had to be in our seat at the table,
my mother's order,
when he came home early,
we left everything we were doing.
Have you dropped everything?
The hockey sticks,
everything your ran in sat your spotter like cause you knew my father had an
adventure to tell and he saunter in like John Wayne himself sit down and say to
us,
guess what kids and we'd all scream,
you were fired.
And then he'd go on and say,
yeah,
told Mr. Stein to go shove it up his butt.
But he use worse language than that.
And he said,
I quit.
I'm not listening to his son.
And of course my mother didn't know how she was gonna feed the kids,
but my father must've interviewed well cause within two weeks he always had
another job.
So there are gaps or k onward to being older.
The lucky break as a young woman,
I was 21 years old being a waitress at the fort lead diner right above my house.
We thought it was a rich town.
Basically.
It wasn't,
it was middle class,
but it looked Richard when we were sitting and I was at a,
at a counter when Ramon Simone looked in and of course this is in him and I
don't have a picture of him,
but he was as drop dead gorgeous as Johnny is a depth,
depth,
depth.
Okay.
Anyway,
he had these aviator navy blue sunglasses on.
You couldn't see his eyes had jet black slick hair.
He had dark olive skin and you had a real suit on other than my father,
I had never seen a man in a suit,
but this was an expensive suit.
I could smell it,
I could feel it.
And not that I touched it,
but you just know.
You know,
one look at him.
I knew I'd be losing my virginity within the week
and it was,
and ironically
it wasn't like I was saving it for anybody,
it's just nobody ever asked for it.
I was
competing with the blonde bombshell at the next counter.
Her name was Gloria and she had a gimmick that was my first real live marketing
gimmick and her gimmick was she would balance two coffee cups on each hand and
she had bosoms like a shoebox before.
I think they even had that surgery actually,
and she would balance to warn each breast and she would hit her way through the
double doors.
And I'm telling you,
the men at the Fort Lee diner waited in line on the concrete steps for an hour
to sit at her countable while I'm washing mine for the third time.
Unfair competition.
But lucky for me only the night before,
how timing makes a difference in life.
The night before I was with my mother and she was hanging the wash and now she's
trying to dish out that wash as fast as she could.
I'm standing there whining and complaining,
mom,
it's not fair.
Nick really should make people,
you know,
one from me,
one five she was getting so many tips union and my mother didn't like
complaining.
You're essentially,
why don't you just maybe break your hair but nice red ribbons to match your
little turtleneck that you were,
cause we had red tournaments and black pinafores.
That was the costume.
And she said,
just stay as sweet as you are.
And I told her that was a stupid idea because I was 21 mothers are stupid.
But of course when I got to the diner I did that with the rubber bands,
the red ribbons.
And I'm telling you,
I found that men like two kinds of women,
the hot tamale,
like this lady or they like the great white virgin either are very,
very innocent.
Okay.
And that I should have went with braids and everything.
Ramon Simone said,
a smart girl like me should really be living in the big city.
I'd grown up in Edgewater,
had never set foot in New York City.
It was a different universe.
It was a mental universe.
We called it the city.
No one ever went there.
And so ray moved me into the Barbizon hotel for women on Lexington Avenue,
which is now a,
I think it's an exercise place of some kind.
But anyway,
it only allowed women to stay there.
Most of them spinsters.
No men were allowed and he paid for a week.
Well,
now my mother definitely had me pegged as a prostitute.
She forbid me to go,
but I was 21 I told her I'm going anyway and off I huffed and was banned from
the house till I drop that terrible guy named Ramon Simone.
After a week,
Ramon Simone gave me a thousand pardon me,
$100 a thousand dollars a hundred dollars to buy myself a New York outfit.
The sounds like prostitution,
but I was so naive,
you know,
and I bought myself a lavender,
one stretch top stretch pants with buttons in a square.
Really Qube a lavender boots.
No,
I didn't have enough for a purse and I walked down Lexington Avenue and I knew I
would never ever leave New York.
It was that moment a week after I was done.
I was like,
this is for me.
I'm Georgy girl.
Cool.
You know,
that kind of thing.
And I never left New York.
I got a receptionist job for the Jif Mooney brothers and answered the phone 50
million times a day and one each.
A phony breads can we need to fully brothers.
I did that for a year and then Ramon Simone said,
you know,
you'd be great as a real estate broker.
He said,
you got such a good personality,
I'm going to give you $1,000.
Let's start a real estate business.
I wish I could take credit for the idea.
Said,
oh,
that was my dream,
wasn't my attitude on nouns.
Hey,
I've had 22 jobs so far,
why not try another one?
That was it.
Bang.
Give it a whirl.
And so we started the Corcoran Simone company with an accent on the Simone
because that was his last name.
And it was very fancy and after all he had explained to me his name was Ramon
Simone.
I pronounced it perfectly and he was from the Basque country,
which had to look up before the advent of the engineer.
You had to actually go to a book and look up Basque country.
Right,
and I found out that they were worries of some kind of spam.
Boy,
was that a turnoff that finished up my virginity right away.
Just that one.
Okay,
so where was I?
All right.
We started the Corcoran,
some own company,
which was a rental company and sublease space on 61st street off of Madison
Avenue,
owned by an accountant.
She bastard.
He raised our rent every month,
but who cares?
He gave us a break initially.
Okay.
Anyway,
that was the beginning of the company.
We had 14 lovely rental agents.
Within seven years I felt on top of the world.
I was actually taking a salary check for the first time on the six year,
whatever it was.
It seemed like a lot at the time and I was thinking,
life doesn't get any better than this.
I had moved in with Ramon Simone after I moved in with him.
He told me he had three daughters.
They moved in with us.
No problem.
I'm good with kids.
Right.
Well surprise.
I also found out from his mother's Vicki that his name was knocked Ramon Simone.
It was ray Simon.
He ended the these
and he was from 150 fifth street,
so I'm like,
well,
there's marketing also.
Okay.
We built that little sales team.
There's a picture of the original team with their old fashioned haircuts and
stuff.
Okay.
On our first little retreat to brainstorm and then almost seven years to the
Itch,
Ramon,
Matt mentioned one night when I was dumping the pastor into the sink,
he said,
you know,
we have something serious to discuss.
Oh yes,
ray.
I looked up through the fog.
They how pretty.
I must look.
I was 29 and he said,
I'm going to marry your secretary,
Tina.
That bitch,
I didn't really say that,
but my head,
I said it.
You know what I mean?
I thought I was in somebody else's bed.
Dream like slow motion when you're in a car crash.
From what I hear,
like what her,
Tina?
No,
he goes,
yeah,
don't get upset.
We're madly in love.
We're going to get married.
He said,
and really take your time moving out.
It was out of there in about a minute with my toothbrush.
Moved on to my best friend and really my only friend because I worked so hard.
He didn't have friends.
Uh,
Kathy Gilson on east 79th street,
had a studio.
I just went right to her house and she let me in and I started living off her
couch until I got my feet under me.
Now what happened after that?
I'm ashamed of because I was a pretty happy go lucky person.
I'm thinking relatively secure.
But somehow when that happened I had,
I felt like my whole insides are pulled out.
What a waste of energy.
After all,
ray had found me in age order.
he believed in me.
He was my mentor,
he was my boyfriend.
He gave me a family I was very,
very,
very fond of is three,
three daughters.
Um,
we worked together.
I mean,
it was my whole world is really,
if you think about it,
but I made the mistaken conclusion that I was strong because of him and nothing
good would have ever happened without him.
All right.
Because that's where I was at that juncture in my life.
I also had the ridiculous idea that had 29 I was old.
My Holy Shit,
nobody's going to marry me.
I'm 29 already
when most women,
especially in edge water,
all my sisters are married at each of their 18th birthday or within months of
it.
Every girl in edge water was married in the early 18th birthday.
So already my parents will sweating it out on me.
I was a haggard old baby,
you know,
and I fell for it myself.
Okay.
But of course,
um,
it took me about a year going in and seeing ray and Tina,
I couldn't fire her.
He said because he was a 51% shareholder,
which was true.
And I didn't want to go in and see them.
And they were married in three months.
So it was really true love.
And they have three kids together.
It was really meant to be and are things all happened like that,
but for me,
I was too naive or too stupid to see it for what it was just meant to be.
It's the way life is.
Right.
Okay.
So it took me a year to get my feet under me.
I pretended for a year,
but when I finally one day somehow got brittle.
I Dunno what clicked.
I can't even tell you what it was.
But I'm marched in on a Friday morning.
I said,
you know,
Ramon,
and this is what we're going to do.
We're going to divide this business.
That's,
oh,
that way.
I'm not that bad looking.
Can I go back 29?
My face was still full.
I had no facial hair.
Then.
There we go.
So I went in and I said,
we're going to chop up this business just like a football draw.
This is my daughter Kate,
but that's what she was six.
She's already nine.
Anyway.
Um,
but it's such a cute picture and I want to show off.
Okay.
All right.
I said,
we're going to chop up this business rate today like a football jersey.
We're going to take the accounts that we have between receivables and what we
actually had in the account.
We had a little bit sure to 70,000 I remember I said we're going to chop it up
35 for you,
35 from me of the cash portion and the receivables.
You get to pick the first person.
We have seven.
We had 14 people,
seven 40 do we have 14 year?
Fortunately we have 14 people.
You get to pick the first person.
I'll pick the second.
You go first and then you could decide if you want to stay here or go and
whether you want the phone number.
We had a great phone number.
I didn't want to lose a phone number,
but you decide,
okay,
you decide,
but we're ending it today.
He couldn't believe it,
but within a minute he picked Norma Hirsch,
the top producers,
60% of my income.
I picked Esther Kaplan like a camel produces steady as she goes.
You know what I mean?
And Chop,
chop,
chop.
I collected my seven people together.
I put them in the corner of the office.
I said,
guess what?
Good News.
Monday,
we're moving our quickly over the weekend.
Give you the new,
just woo.
Yeah,
we're moving on Monday.
I didn't tell them the others were moving with us,
you know,
and I said,
come back for work on Monday morning,
but I'll give you the address over the weekend.
I went to my existing landlord on third avenue and 58th street and I got the
exact same office,
two floors higher than rate eight nine three floors high.
He was on eight I got 11 I got to for 20% cheaper.
Now,
that to me sounded like God's will that I was getting a lucky break,
but guess what?
It really wasn't.
What it meant was the real estate market was about to crash because the
commercial sector of the market always goes before the residential,
but I didn't know that then and I should have had it.
Be careful,
be careful,
but I didn't hear that in those days.
You could take a cab down to 42nd street,
you could buy all your desks right on the street and the guys would physically
run them up to your office and put them together.
You could order the telephone.
Ma Bell was a big,
big deal in town.
You could order a telephone on a Friday having stolen Saturday morning.
That's what I did.
And one day morning came,
we had desks,
chairs in a phone or what do you need in the real estate business?
Just people.
And they moved into that ass and they sat down and we were in business.
Bang.
I decided to call the company the Corcoran Group,
cause I figured if I was going to make it,
I was going to need the help of the group.
And that was the beginning of the Corcoran group when I left the door that day,
uh,
when we ended that business,
because ray rightfully,
I think now in hindsight was angry.
I was like,
Hey,
he getting hit broadside.
Okay.
Uh,
but ray gave me the gift of a lifetime.
He said to me,
you know,
Barbara,
you will never succeed without me.
And you know what if he had said,
you know Barbara,
you're amazing.
I'm sure you'll do fine.
I don't believe I would have stayed in business in the tough times.
It was my sheer ego of that insult that Burns so deep in my soul that went,
all the chips are down.
I thought I had tried everything in the world,
every that I could possibly think to stay in business,
highly leveraged because real estate goes up and down and up and down.
I was always leveraged cause I was always greedy about where I wanted to go.
But I would think of those words and son of a gun,
I would think one new thing.
And that one new thing was always the thing that got me through.
So he really gave me a gift.
Thank you.
And of course he was wrong cause I sold my business maybe 22 years later for 66
million now for the next part.
Okay.
All right.
[inaudible]
well this one isn't on my slide so we'll see where we're going.
Now I'm a shark.
I can read the damn thing.
There we go.
Now I'm a shark.
And that's the shark tank set.
I got the shark tank Gig as a result of handling rejection as I do so well.
Very well.
Yet again,
everything good in my life always happened on the heels of rejection.
And so when I was hired to do shark tank,
I signed the contract without even reading it,
sent it back to Mark Burnett,
Mark Burnett,
a file,
famous produce.
I'm going to Hollywood.
I'm going to see the Hollywood on the hill sign.
I'm like,
I bought three new outfits to sign autographs.
I'm going to be famous.
Oh my God.
I was so excited.
And then only four days before I was supposed to fly out to la,
I got the dreaded phone call.
I'm sorry we hired somebody else.
We changed your mind.
All right.
And that's when I wrote the email.
Thank God standing up for myself with the help of everyone in my office who's
actually here.
And let me not forget to introduce them somewhere in the dark in a minute.
Um,
I wrote the email to Mark Burnett telling him I considered his rejection,
a lucky charm,
cited all the negative things that happened in my life and how they turned
around to be the best possible things.
And enter the email is saying,
I suggest you in by both girls out to compete for the lone female seat and I'll
pay for my own plate plane fare and I'll be on that plane.
And when he read that,
his comment to his secretary of the secretary of the secretary that was standing
there,
she told it Shariece I think it was a name,
she said,
all he said is,
God,
she's a shark.
And invited me out.
Thank God if not for that email,
I would not have gotten that.
I would not have met any of the entrepreneurs that I do like my own children
when they're making money
and even the bad ones when they're not making my kind of like him too.
Okay.
Uh,
but I thought it might be very interesting for you to hear,
uh,
what I believe makes for a successful entrepreneur.
All right on there.
My original group from season one and two.
Um,
maybe you recognize some of those people.
My favorite of course is the two guys at the top,
especially the one on your left saving.
He's so God damn sexy.
I can't even talk to them without breathing heavy.
Okay.
All right.
Number one trait.
Uh,
probably in descending order or at least the first few of the key persistence,
the inability to quit.
Every one of my entrepreneurs that are hugely successful have that in spades.
I don't know where to get it.
Or you're born with and you develop it.
Do you do it from the school of hard knocks?
I Dunno how you get it,
but I know one thing for sure is investor.
If you don't have it,
you're not going to succeed.
You can have everything else,
but if you don't have that low Iq that when someone's slams you on the head,
you go down and then you bounce up and go,
I'm going to ask some Donald backup.
Hit me again.
It's like a weird thing
that kind of a thing that goes on.
The ability to handle a hard hit is key.
And I have been able to separate early on now my investments very quickly on one
little thing that happens in the minute I see it happened,
I'm like,
Oh God,
I'm going to lose my money.
And as cold feeling sorry for yourself when I'm talking to one of my
entrepreneurs will say we did the due diligence,
we sign up the deal and working with them now for two to three months and
something really bad happens.
A disappointment.
If they start doing a oh poor me like Oh God,
Oh my God that wasn't fair.
You know she wrote I on the book,
the minute I hear that talk,
I know I'm gonna lose my money because the difference between the really great
entrepreneurs and everyone else's,
how long they take to feel sorry for themselves.
I really believe that.
And so if you're the type that just boom and like oh shit that shouldn't have ha
what and keep working,
you're going to do well as an entrepreneur.
Persistence to tell you her story by way of illustration,
daisy was selling 200 cakes.
I believe I might be off on my numbers cause I always make some hops around
them.
Out Mountain your own head.
200 cakes on shark type before she appeared on shark tank.
Boom.
Every guy in America fell in love with her.
She was a girl next door.
Every guy ordered a cake but website crash.
She was out of business.
But what did daisy do?
She's smart enough to pick up the fall and say here's what I'm doing.
And I got wonderful.
She doesn't mind me imitating he has wanted to do and I got one full on here.
Now I'm going to afford that phone line.
And this was a message when she knew I wouldn't pick a,
I'm going to follow that fall onto your phone line in New York and you get a
bunch of girls.
It's sal at me and start taking cake orders
and that's exactly what we did.
Three good actresses it Santa Hello is this daisy cakes?
Each show is,
what did she do?
Okay,
she's amazing.
She has over a million dollars in sales and cakes.
Okay.
If I had to say one trait that I've seen in this lady over and over again is she
knows how to get hit hard and make a lot of bed business judgements,
but I don't really care about them cause I know she's going to come back up.
Persistence.
Okay.
Cousins,
Maine lobster,
you already decided for you?
My handsome Hong Kong,
the right when I come back in to pray to God.
Let me be born as wife
and if he's not available I'll take gym.
Okay.
Uh,
cousins,
Maine lobster,
when they were on shark tank,
they were in business three months.
They had great trade as they are street smart.
Again,
common to all my great entrepreneurs.
But I'll give you a story to illustrate it.
Um,
they were selling lobsters out of a food truck.
Bang.
They were in the food truck.
Uh,
they had three months of sales.
They were so well prepared that they had listened to four seasons of shark tank
had written down every question,
any entrepreneur I had ever been asked.
And they came up with two answers.
If they got asked [inaudible] they were practiced.
They were so smooth on the set.
I thought their business for 10 years,
not a single sharks,
they'd,
they'd say our monthly sales are,
they never said how long you've been in business.
They never said it.
No one has.
There is that savvy on their feet.
I was lucky shark that won that competition to get them.
They grew their one food trucks to 10 food trucks.
They just opened a restaurant.
They're making money hand over fist already.
They also opened an online cousins being lops and direct a lobsters right to
your door,
that kind of thing.
Anywhere.
A very important part of shark tank to illustrate them in action is something we
call updates.
When you have a successful entrepreneur,
the show likes to come back and do an update on the,
hey,
what's happening?
And the viewers at home really like that part of the show.
When I pitched shark tank,
oh listen,
they're getting an award from the governor's office in Maine,
uh,
for creating 50 new jobs in the state.
It's a worst economy of all the states,
the worst job market.
They are,
they are.
You want to shoot it?
Yeah,
we love it.
And then I call the governor's office.
Hey,
shark tank once a chute,
they want you to give them an award for 15 years
jobs.
Okay,
but here's what he has.
What went awry.
Okay.
Uh,
a day before they said,
we're not only going to shoot them on the dock,
we're going to come and shoot them with the governor.
We're going to do two part.
The first two part update they ever did.
Whoever.
I had a two parts.
We had the two parts come from.
The second part is we're going to go to the factory and shoot the 50 people.
Hi cousins.
How many friends do you have in Maine
and how quickly can you get chef hats with cousins and bright red printed?
So your brand is branded on TV.
I don't know.
We'll do our best.
They had 50 custommade chef hats within 24 hours.
50 employees of sorts in their factory smiling.
But when the executive,
not,
not when the field producer walked in,
a little tighten of a guy walked in,
he saw all these happy workers with big hats on which I blew garbage bags
individually to puff them up.
We're all standing,
here's the workers and when he walked in,
he goes,
great,
but the chef has to have to go there just too much and saving my loverboy here.
Cooley turns around and says,
you know,
he said,
unfortunately,
we never let our chefs work without them as company policy
and the
the guy rolled right off.
I'll go,
okay,
what was most important in this update is every shot of them had the brand in
it.
And what do you think happened to their brand new website that had no sales?
It exploded with business.
All right,
fast on your feet,
smart on your feet,
not the kind of stuff you get when you pay all that money for Harvard Mba,
street smarts,
street smarts.
How do you get out of the,
how do you finagle and how do you do a fast key quality?
In my entrepreneur next,
Tom and she,
when I met Tom and Chee,
they were had just come out of selling their grilled cheese on donuts out of
attendance.
Cincinnati.
All right.
What was so interesting about them?
However,
they weren't talking about a 10 they were talking about a franchise of hundreds
of franchise.
Sell Him.
She's a donuts.
Okay.
All right.
What do you think happened?
They told me about they're going to have an amusement park one day,
a Tom and chee amusement park.
I'm like,
okay.
They're definitely on dope.
All right,
but I don't think so anymore.
I can't wait to go to the museum park.
They have 171 franchise across America.
Exactly what they envisioned.
They got exactly the picture in great detail where they're going to do it,
how they're going to go to the other side of the river in Cincinnati,
which is another state.
I forget which one it is,
how they're going to come across back,
blah,
blah.
I'm like,
okay,
well guess what?
I should have believed them.
Okay.
They have big pictures in their head and every entrepreneur might not have a
business plan with everything.
In fact,
none of the really do I think the grossly overrated,
but they sure have a movie in their head of who they're going to be when they
grow up.
Right.
And when they can't express that movie on Shark Tank,
I'm always out Vikki they don't see it.
How am I going to see it and believe it and they're not going to get their
visual big picture.
I don't know if fleet would deserves to be here because he's still not making me
any money,
but he is a big visionary thinker and he's always pissing away my money on his
ideas.
But I have to say I got to stay with them here because I'm going to contract
with mostly and I also love him and his own bed child kind of way,
but whatever.
Let me move on.
Okay,
next.
I'm so,
I have a hard time being a phony baloney.
Okay.
What does it say?
Sales ability?
Yes,
definitely Tom and Chee Harlem,
New York.
They originally in Brooklyn,
moved to Harlem in New York under the train tracks.
Interesting view of their business.
You go there,
you can't hear each other uhmm
but they have the happiest bakery do a pip corn.
What's pip corn?
Small kernels of popcorn that doesn't upset your stomach if you have any kind of
food allergies,
lactose,
blah,
all that stuff and it doesn't get caught in your teeth and it's delicious.
They discovered pip corn because Jen had a stomach problem.
Brother and sister team Jen is probably the most charismatic person I've ever
met in my life.
She walks into whole foods and everybody's crawling up to dine at touch her.
She's got charisma.
She sells that popcorn to anybody and everybody and they keep coming back for
more.
What does a great brother do?
And he's a finance guy named Ian Union Union.
Ina Lena,
Lena,
Lena.
Couldn't be better partners.
And what does he do?
He even goes out and marries a financial,
uh,
what?
What an investment banker,
another Bree and her into the business.
What does Jen do?
She hires a best friend to run the factory.
What does that lady do?
She knows how to make those popcorn popper so happy.
Amazing.
But she's selling every minute of the day.
No matter who shit.
It's natural to her.
Phenomenal sales ability.
Charisma.
Another one,
hold your heart.
Just same thing.
These girls tell you you should buy their pants for fat girls acids and I'm
telling you I'm going to buy two Paris because they just,
how you got to have holiday honches you got to buy in.
No one do.
They have $1 million a sale by year two in shark tank.
One of the best success stories.
Next risk tolerant.
Great Trade.
Okay.
This guy bought into him because he looks just like a pig.
Do you know how?
No.
In a good way.
All right.
Talk Bowel barbecue sauce.
Think about it.
Anybody old enough in this room to remember that guy who used to sell chicken,
so there's like a chicken.
Frank Perdue looked exactly like a chicken.
I saw this guy go,
he's a new frank Perdue,
but he's a pig.
Okay,
what's great about no,
and he doesn't even mind it.
He thinks he knows for what it is.
Okay,
and he's married.
He's more secure now with two kids.
All right.
But when he was single then even then he accepted it.
What's great about them is their risk tolerance.
When I say risk tower,
and I believe this,
they,
when their business was young and they had a buy shelves and shelves in the
stores is no way to get those shelves unless you paying for them.
They had a vision of a giant business.
They went out and they raised like 800,000 maybe I did less.
Maybe it was one,
two.
They made it like $800,000 when they could barely stay in business and they blew
it all.
I'm more shelf space.
They can go for broke.
They're not the least bit bothered.
And their attorneys,
their Washington DC attorneys when they decided to go with this business,
quite an unusual thing.
Competitive.
If I tell Jim from cousins,
Maine Lobster,
I don't have his picture here,
but you know I talked about him before.
If I tell him one little thing about the guy he used to compete with on the
hockey team.
Jim was a semi professional hockey player and had some injury or something in
the minor leagues,
if I'm telling that right,
but anyway,
his arch enemy on the other team was a guy named Luke.
What do you think happened?
Luke's for main gyms for me and Luke went into the lobster business.
All I have to do to double sales and say,
Hey gee,
here,
Luke opening another restaurant.
Talk about competitive spirit.
He's ready to kill.
He doesn't stop working.
He hates the idea that somebody might beat him at a game.
It says DNA and his partner savings the same way.
All I have to do is tell grace and lace who makes beautiful lacy socks and
shawls and I my most successful business by foreign terms of making money and
what do I have to do to get them going?
Hardly anything.
Well,
I got to do is I,
God got a big check from a cousins today,
but you know,
I'll get a check from her like within the week,
a bigger check.
They're winning when it was successful.
Why I didn't say compete with my mother.
That's the way they weren't competitive.
You get an entrepreneur who doesn't feel the heat of competition.
He's not going to be good on his feet.
She's not going to come to the fore when she really needs it.
That competitive spirit drives you through all the things that don't make any
common sense in life.
That's what it does.
Okay?
They're my entrepreneur.
Isn't my house in Utah that we just did an update on a facade?
Let me tell you the great thing that I find about working with these people.
This is a repeat of what I did at the Corcoran group.
I hired people.
I developed talent.
I love my people to death.
I spoiled him rotten.
I tried to make them the best they could be and I enjoyed every single second of
it.
My greatest satisfaction work with these UNPRI entrepreneurs.
The good ones,
not the bad ones that take your money in the night,
okay?
The good ones is there.
My salespeople all over again.
They are phenomenally successful.
Now,
what are the sharks really liked?
With three minutes and 44 seconds left.
I could tell I'm talking too much.
I'll give you the low down.
Okay.
What's Kevin O'leary like?
Everybody thinks he's a mean guy.
He's the pusher over the show in real life.
He's a pushover.
When his wife walks onto the set,
you could visibly see him shaking on his knees.
I'm not making that up,
okay?
He,
he fancies himself a very big consortia and doesn't have the common sense to
know,
know the label.
O'Leary wines is not a good fit for wine.
All right?
Whatever.
Okay,
I'll Kevin's game for anything on the show.
He'll pose,
he'll do anything.
He,
we have more weird pictures of Kevin.
Okay.
But he's an absolute sweetheart.
I'm only going to tell you the first half of the story.
You could use your imagination on the second.
Kevin is never ready to leave the set at the end of a long 10 hour day and it's
a long day.
Trust me.
It's like being in a army pick all day with a bunch of people.
All right?
So to get him to change and calm,
I ripped his pants down.
I saw us behind.
And you use imagination on the front.
It wasn't much.
Yeah.
What's Robert Hirsch Avec really like?
He definitely is gay and should come out
okay.
Constantly tell him.
But what's great about Robert is he's a show and a half within the show.
We all go out there,
bring two dresses.
You have to wear the same clothes,
bring two identical dresses.
I fell for that the first three years until I realized I was painful.
No,
I'm bringing one dress and let's hope it lasts.
Okay.
Robert brings racks of 50 suits,
50 shirts,
50 cufflinks,
different color ties.
And then you've got to do the Robert Ritual on the first day of filming.
Do you like this?
Tie the shirt.
What do you think about this shirt?
Just put on the fucking shit.
Wow.
Robert,
please come out.
You'd be such a happy man.
He's always kissing men.
I've never seen him kiss women.
I put that in simply because I look young.
Okay.
I put that in cause I thought I looked better than Lori.
Oh,
oh yeah.
What's Laurie like?
Laurie's all about hair.
It's unfair.
I get one minute my hair,
Laurie gets two hours.
Okay.
Laurie is about her hair all the time.
Her hair,
her hair,
let it go,
Lori.
But Lori's great credit.
She's the best merchandise around the whole set.
She gets a product that she likes.
She's gonna Slam it home.
She's a gorilla.
I can't compete with her in that.
None of the men could compete with us.
She's phenomenal.
And she has our single best success to date in terms of quick money.
I went on the long term money,
but she's waiting on the quick money Scrub Daddy Damon Damon's hysterical.
It's a shame.
They edit all of Damon's comments out cause we'd be a much better show.
He's filthy.
But he comes across rather stayed on the show.
I think I'm like,
that sounds Damon.
They edit all the good stuff that he is a chick magnet.
You walk into any place that Damien,
500 women are surrounding you.
I almost get stampeded.
Hey,
there's something about him.
I think it's the way he uses his hands.
So cause I get turned on by that a little.
He's such as smoochy.
So I airbrush my face there.
What's Mark Cuban like?
He's filthy rich.
That's what's wrong with them.
I've learned that there's a huge difference between a millionaire and a
billionaire.
Okay.
He basically does it for sport.
Mark.
I'll be in the makeup chair the next morning.
I can't believe you plunk down $1 million on that guy and gave him a $400,000
salary.
He said,
you know,
I got to keep the guys busy bar.
He gets grumpy.
You got to loosen this guy up.
Okay.
But he's the smartest shark in my opinion,
across many levels.
I think he's got such a wide range of smartness in so many areas.
Okay.
And when he's wrong,
he's smart enough.
Never to admit it.
I've lost my most money with mark.
Okay.
Behind the scenes of shark tank.
I'll just click through them.
We get famous people on the set.
It's a blast.
They make us wear all kinds of crap.
Okay.
Oh,
this is automatic.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
Uh,
you know,
he'd go struck crazy on that set one pitch looks like another.
Okay.
All right.
Um,
they got props Galore.
Okay.
On and on.
They married Kevin and I twice now.
It's ridiculous.
Okay.
Kevin loves stuff on his face or anything.
He'll wear it.
There's Damon.
I think that's a repeat.
Right?
Okay.
Dusting his head.
How many times a day does his hair get dusted with powder?
Mr. Wonderful.
500 okay.
People love to imitate him.
Damon.
That was an outfit they said to him,
you can't wear that.
No,
He goes to wet to weigh out on his clothes.
Okay.
All right.
Side benefits.
You get preferential treatment.
Now I get the best tables.
My assistant Gail calls,
we always get a table.
Even if they're full guys.
I gave them my doll to this rock star.
I still don't know his name and he took her home.
He's been sleeping with her.
That gives me a thrill.
That's the executive producer.
That's his child that was born in year ones.
Now six year old.
That guy with the,
for the most important guide because he's in charge of light lighting.
I mean they're going to look good or bad based on him.
These are updates.
They're thrilling to do.
Updates are more exciting to do.
The opening shots of shots with the jets.
It's like,
wow,
I'm somebody cool man.
I'm cool.
Red Carpets,
people flashing at you.
Oh yeah,
I'm cool,
I'm cool.
And all that kind of stuff.
Okay.
Shooting the updates with the entrepreneurs is fabulous.
That's at my beach house.
We did an update there before we did the ski one a shooting or shooting them run
around the county.
My youngest entrepreneur,
he's only eight now he's 12 I picked send my dollar round.
You saw that doll when I can't show up.
That's my pig guy.
Now he's married.
That's a good pig.
Pig.
Pig,
pig.
Okay.
It gets even those guys a double kiss
daisy cakes,
grace and lace Grayson,
lace Grayson lays opening orphanages in India.
Two of them in their first year.
They're making that much money and there's my team and an answer to the final
question.
Do we like each other?
Yes.
You have to spend that much time with somebody.
You're going to wind up either hate them.
I liked them and we really like each other and respect each other and that's it.
And I went over 40 seconds.
[inaudible]
we only have to take 40 seconds.
I was a question answer.
So what questions do you have?
Anything and the bravest person always raises a hand first.
This guy,
oh,
you're popping up.
Is that how you dress for work by the way?
I don't mind.
I'm just curious.
Really.
It's,
I like the work.
Um,
I think this is even below Google.
I would agree with that and I don't even know Google.
Um,
I just want to say full sit.
First of all.
That's phenomenal.
Thank you.
Especially the entrance.
I think that was like the best entrance that anyone's made.
I you a schmoozer
no,
it was good.
If it sucked,
it sucked,
I would tell you.
Yeah.
You know what?
I predict you're going to be the head of this organization by kissing ass
made.
Maybe if I dress better.
Uh,
but,
um,
I was wondering,
I see the show have seen it like my parents love it.
I notice a lot of stuff gets edited out.
The parents love it today.
Thank you.
They're so excited that I'm here.
It's kind of funny.
Um,
they,
I noticed that a lot of stuff gets edited out or like there are a lot of,
a lot of jumps and I'm wondering like what gets edited out,
you know,
like,
do they actually tell you more?
I mean,
they must tell you more than what they show the viewers.
You don't just make a decision off of like,
oh,
hey,
you know,
um,
well,
three minutes.
No.
All right.
The reality is,
is a typical pitch is 45 minutes to an hour and a half when you're sitting at
home,
it's six minutes.
All right?
A good editor tries to eliminate those jumps.
Very,
very hard to do.
Okay?
Uh,
we know nothing about the entrepreneur when they walked through that fake tunnel
with the fake sharks.
Okay?
We know nothing.
All right.
And we are expected to make a deal on the set was very little knowledge other
than what they represent.
But what the entrepreneur is also made to do prior to appearing on shark is to
assign extensive documents saying that they know it's not a real deal.
If we choose not to close,
roughly I'd say 65% of the deals close.
I really don't know that as a fact,
but my sense of it is close.
I'm sure.
And I know that's true of me.
I close about 60% of what you'll see me.
I'm in,
you know,
of course things go awry when you do the deal with diligence.
Not that people lie,
but they're under pressure.
It's TV,
it's alive,
not professional actors and actresses and like the,
the,
the patent that they definitely have really zoned by the brother-in-law,
you know,
things go a little loosey Goosey.
Okay.
And so they added a lot out.
Uh,
but also add on to that,
it's owned by Disney world.
Disney is the parent company and they want it clean.
Okay.
So my great line for the two women that had the motorcycle jackets,
uh,
and I had a terrible name.
The first thing I said is,
hey girls,
you got to name this dykes on bikes.
And I couldn't wait to see that episode when I sound like that was genius.
Barbara date somebody
so memorable.
Well the men on the set,
it's like,
yeah,
that's great.
I love it.
I love it and never made air.
Okay.
So a lot of that risque stuff has to come out.
Including Damon's jokes.
Sadly because he's a stoical they'd never make year.
And so did I answer your question?
I think.
And what's your name?
Cause you should be ashamed of yourself.
What's your name and what's your last name?
I want to remember.
It's Al Nagee.
Hyphenated.
Ah,
okay.
I'll watch yourself.
Okay.
Who else?
It's hard.
It's hard to see what the light wave if you got oh,
oh,
you're doing a line thing organized.
Okay.
Hi,
it's nice to meet you.
Thank you so much for being here.
So my question is less about shark tank.
Well,
I do love the show,
but my boyfriend is trying to break into the real estate industry in New York
and he's finding it a little bit challenging.
So I just wanted to know what advice you would have for somebody who's trying to
start off.
Yeah,
well,
the first thing you should do is go and work for top salesperson.
Best way to go in,
the easiest job to get in New York if you want to go in real estate,
is to go to rental company.
It's like the bottom feeders right there.
It's terrible.
But you know what's great about it.
And I ran a rental company for seven years before I was eight years for one's a
sales,
thank God.
And you know what's great about it?
You get a hundred times at Bat.
In other words,
you answered 50 calls.
Wa is that apartment available?
That apartment available different.
When you're selling,
it's a slow motion.
So you get a lot of practicing.
If you could work as a free slave,
you in for a licensed top salesperson just sitting next to them being their
slave and servant,
you're going to learn everything.
You can't learn in a real estate school.
You gotta be on the street and learn it.
And so that's the most important thing,
you know.
And if you need an introduction,
just give me the car.
I'll pretend I know your boyfriend.
Is there anything like you
I,
yeah,
you sure?
Cause obviously,
wait,
what did you say?
That I'm a little better,
but he's pretty great.
Well I'll definitely introduce them to my recommendation to you.
Is you feeling that way right now?
Do not marry this
[inaudible]
yes.
A little.
I'm sorry,
I didn't see that.
Mike.
Hi.
How are you ladies?
A pretty dress.
I may you earlier.
Thank you.
You inspire me.
So my question is when you also having to do with your career,
when you started real estate,
I mean sales aspect was always sexy and fun and interesting,
but it was really dominated by men who are power brokers and suits and if I
understand correctly,
um,
and it wasn't an industry that was for sparkling bubbly women who have big
personalities.
So I'm,
I'm an attorney which is not known for having a big personalities or including
the ones who made the wrong career decision.
Right?
Well,
no,
I mean there's some good there.
I'm not vouching for attorney,
but um,
but how do you balance being taken in the beginning were about balancing,
being able to be in front of Titans of industry and being taken seriously in
front of them,
but also being true to who you are and letting people see your personality.
You know,
the one great thing about getting older than,
than you fall apart,
which is really sickening and horrific.
It really is.
You find something new every day.
You don't like physically about yourself,
especially with the tend to be self critical.
And 99% of women out there are in 99% of men don't even have that gene from what
I see.
Okay.
But here we go.
I think it is essential to almost be ignorant.
You know what I mean?
I never felt like a woman in a man's field.
And by the way,
when I started,
all the companies were owned by men.
They weren't,
oh my one.
But they were worked by women.
The bosses are men.
The women showed the apartments and the general cut of woman,
a woman who showed the apartments for sale on parking fifth,
remember it was a limited high end market.
That was it.
You didn't have third second Tribeca.
The village,
she didn't have that.
Okay.
That Pete,
that was a vibrant rental market sale market.
You had narrow corridors on the east and west side and they were society women.
If you knew the right people,
you could sell them.
That wasn't me.
And it was a huge disadvantage to me.
Okay.
That was the disadvantage.
My upbringing and my lack of connections more than I was a female.
They were men at the Duh.
But it was a huge advantage to me to start hiring women.
I had probably in my firm,
my guess is 75 women before any man ever wanting to work for me.
I interviewed men,
but they'd walk in and see a pool of women and like they were in and out until
Ralph Kruger showed up and said,
I have a pushy wife and too pushy daughters.
I love it here.
So I sat him right in the front so a man could walk in Cmn,
that kind of thing.
But I think it's very important to almost be dumb.
Uh,
and she's,
Oh,
I forgot where I was going.
The upside when you're getting much older,
and I've gotten stronger and stronger in this way as I by the year,
by the minute.
Okay.
And I wish I knew it earlier.
It's to be yourself because people,
even if you're weird,
a Weirdo is often the most loved person in a team.
I think if you could be yourself and all that,
it is,
what typically happens is people like you because they can sense it's a real
deal.
It's the heirs,
the phoniness or trying to impress the insecurity,
all the stuff that we all strive so hard for when we're young that gets in the
way.
You know,
there was actually a two year period where I had my hair poofed up and didn't
wash it all week to try to fit in with the society ladies,
you know,
but my scalp itch like crazy.
I had to get rid of that haircut,
you know,
poof thing once a week.
Hello?
Hey.
Yeah,
and the only time my business ever fell behind it was when I was so busy
watching my competition.
I analyzed everything.
I had that listings on a chart by category by size,
who had one,
who was my doctor at the time.
I was like a genius at my field.
It was the only year of my whole career.
I never pushed the business ahead.
I was so busy watching the next guy was watching me.
Right.
So being itself,
I would say would be the most important thing.
I forget about the female male thing.
I'm not saying it's not important.
Certain industries.
Certainly if you're an attorney,
investment banker,
it's such a man's world is a lot of man's world out there.
But entrepreneurship,
is it a level playing field?
There's no rules.
And you know what I find,
and sorry I meant to say this,
but I find women can work in a real weird,
never mind.
They work harder,
they work harder,
they would just work harder,
you know?
Uh,
and maybe that's driven a little bit by insecurity,
but for whatever it's worth.
That's my 2 cents.
Your question.
Sorry,
I'm so long winded.
No,
good question though.
Yeah.
Hi Barbara.
My name is Francine and the eyes,
faith family.
Five kids.
And you have a 10 yeah,
I didn't have my mother had no your mother.
Yeah.
Okay.
I have two.
Yeah.
Two.
Thank you for being your authentic self.
I think your story was really motivating and inspiring for us.
So my question for you as you speak to so many businesses,
once you do bring them on,
what are the top questions these businesses asked to be fast growth,
high profit businesses and how do you address them?
What are the questions?
The small businesses ask me,
me,
my entrepreneurs that I,
uh,
I'm in partnership with.
Yes.
Um,
you know,
it's funny,
everybody has different questions.
Okay.
Um,
I never really thought about that.
So good one.
All the categories because I think of them as old individual businesses.
You know what?
I don't think I'm aware of what questions cause I have my own agenda,
my agenda when I'm getting together on Skype calls,
emails,
whatever is how do I push this business ahead?
How do I grow it?
So one thing I know how to do,
I'm not sure I'm good at anything other than I,
I know how to take some small and make it big.
All right?
Some thinking angles.
How do we multiply that?
How do we multiply like my mother did the socks.
Same kind of thing.
I'm not [inaudible] my brain's going like that.
So the advice and I'm almost always doing is the pushing them,
pushing them,
pushing them.
You try it,
try it.
And you know what I've also learned,
I've learned with all the good entrepreneurs are really successful ones.
When they asked me for advice,
you all,
we have this situation,
Barbara,
I'd like you,
Bubba,
and I go and give them my best advice.
All valid.
You know what they do?
They do as they please my best entrepreneurs,
listen to my advice and then don't do it.
And that's an entrepreneur.
It's an independent streak for the same reason my dad should have been lunch
manure.
They don't want anybody telling them what to do even though they ask.
All right,
so it's not exactly your answer cause I'm not sure I have it,
but that's the best I could do.
Okay.
Pleasure.
You're a cool guy with the hands in your pocket.
Money.
Yeah,
the jacket to the guy in the short.
Okay.
You should give me your pants,
Michael.
Don't tease me.
Don't disappoint me.
If we go there,
we can do this all day long for some color was so down for me.
Say that again.
Long time viewer.
And in the vein of being a longtime viewer,
I'm curious why you think the show is such a success.
It had to catch on it.
It had to catch on the first couple of seasons.
I constantly moved our time slot in a day of the week learner for a show.
People just find you,
well that was a fun show and you want to watch you again.
They don't promote it.
They were do no promotion of the show.
The next week it landed on a different day,
different time slot.
Then they moved it again.
Just as we started getting trashed,
they kept moving it because we weren't as successful show.
And what happens is you got to like chat,
have a trial by fire.
When United successful show,
very few of them survived.
Very few.
I think it's like 1% of all shows that open ever stay on air.
Okay.
And so we were tenuous as years and that was the biggest problem.
And then we got loyal followers,
you know and I knew this show is going to be successful.
I remember the day some babe,
this lady,
Weird lady followed me into a restroom at the shuttle building in a near Kennedy
airport,
wherever that thing is by Laguardia,
you know that Shell Delta shuttle couldn't remember the name,
followed me in hustle mean in the John.
I mean,
one thing,
walk me to the saint,
but walk me in the Gi weird and she's like,
I love shopping.
Okay.
And you know what I thought I thought she's just like my born again.
Nutjob sister Christian.
I thought these are like born again Christian people and not if you're born
again Christian.
I know that's not supposed to say that.
You know,
there's somebody,
somebody who's really found God and I was gone for her and I to myself.
Whoa.
That's pretty intense.
And after that we started hearing everybody till the lie all the time.
You and my favorite shark and my favorite sharks.
I was traveling with Kevin O'leary at an airport once and a woman got on the
way.
Thank God not in the stall on the way to the stall.
Said to me,
you and my favorite shark.
You my favorite shark.
I said thank you.
Thank you.
I always believe that.
Then I get outside.
And what do you think happened?
She was outside talking to Kevin and I hear her say are my favorite shark.
How could he be her favorite shark and maybe her favorite shirt on mine?
Yeah,
you happy?
You could take your hands out of your pocket now did you want the jacket?
No,
and I don't want the other party that can sit down
now.
Your mom,
nighttime.
You're a hog.
We're not going to like me after this.
Okay.
You want to preface this by saying you,
you did say you would answer any question.
So hello.
Your eyes are twittering.
You're nervous.
I'm nervous.
Go ahead.
You scare me a little bit.
One of,
one of my favorite anecdotes of yours is your letter to Mark Burnett and I'm
amazed at how you handled it.
I loved reading the text of it.
What I'd like to know is who was the younger blonde you were competing with?
Oh,
shark tank.
I can't tell you that.
You said are only thing I want to answer it,
but you know why I couldn't end now I lied.
I didn't mean to,
cause I will answer anything,
but you know why I can't answer.
Uh,
because she was a scoring lover and it would feel if,
if it came back to her,
it wouldn't be right.
Okay.
So my working theory that it was Laurie not correct.
No,
you're not a wrap.
That's kind of a lorry look alike.
Okay.
Kind of a look lookalike.
Yeah.
All right.
Okay.
Thank you.
Sorry I wasn't good for my word,
but it would be too mean spirited.
No,
I'm just joking.
You good.
Thank you very much.
Not only a had long blonde hair,
just like Tina miles secretary who stole my boyfriend.
Okay.
She'll say you do you know what's,
and we'll want to,
all I had to do is do one click online.
I got while I was rejected.
Uh,
well,
I you made,
that's not really fair,
but I assumed,
I knew.
You know what I mean?
And I knew I had tremendous liabilities to overcome their age one.
Clearly,
you know,
I'm old enough to be able to shrugs mothers.
I really am.
Damon said to me one time,
he said,
you're not old enough to be own mother.
I said,
yeah.
just think about it Damon.
If they catch up black guy that raped my mother at 20,
they're going to put him behind jail bars.
Get that.
It's a joke.
Damien loved it.
Sorry.
Damon loved it.
He goes,
that's the funniest thing I have already.
That's why I'm your son.
Right.
It,
this isn't recorded is it?
I'm serious.
This,
this recording.
Well,
if it is whoever's recording x that out,
cause I could get me in trouble,
you know,
anything out a context.
Right.
Yeah.
And then I have to get Damon to come testify.
Okay.
All right.
Come up with a different question.
Oh,
you're my favorite chart.
Yes ma'am.
I know you said Damon gets cut,
but I think you might get your airtime cuddle a little bit to too.
Huh?
Um,
no day.
Oh,
you mean with my filthy mouth?
They cutting you out a lot too.
Yeah.
Um,
so my question is you didn't look like the type that was going to say that
coming at your strong.
Um,
so what,
who is this woman?
Um,
so what if any sharks do you prefer
for working with?
Um,
I like working with Mark Cuban.
You know why he's got a great team around him.
Uh,
he's quick to decide.
Bam,
Bam.
Thank you ma'am.
He doesn't take a lot of time on the due diligence and it gets down to business
and what to say.
He's extremely bright,
extremely bright on many,
many ways.
He's bright.
Okay.
And something about having a billionaire,
whether it's right or wrong,
put their money in the business.
You're putting a millionaire business money in,
um,
makes you feel like you're smarter.
Okay.
Yeah.
So anybody that you don't like working with,
who is this woman?
Okay.
Um,
you know what,
I've done deals with all of the entrepreneurs and um,
I actually liked doing deals myself.
Think about it.
When you do a deal with another,
a shark,
you've got to agree on terms of the contract.
You've got to compare due diligence.
You've got emails going back and forth.
It's hugely inefficient.
I like to decide,
get it done and move on because only when we really have in life is our time.
So anything that's inefficient,
I'm more of a chip off my mother's block.
It is inefficient.
I don't want to mess with [inaudible],
you know,
so really by myself and I've done deals with everybody,
but I never mind doing a deal with mark.
Yep.
Okay,
thanks.
Although mark didn't tell me not to invest in this phenomenal deal because he
knew all about franchising,
he really did.
I didn't invest in who will remain nameless.
And then one of the biggest hits on Shark tank proving that just because
somebody has more money than that.
Smarter than you.
Yeah.
Yes.
Wow.
You're like a kind of a cowboy type.
Um,
so I kind of have two questions.
Yes.
Oh,
start with one and maybe I'll get to the other one.
Um,
so the phone,
what the hell?
Go for two.
All right.
So the first question I had kind of do a shark tank,
it itself.
So like when you're paying entrepreneurs,
how much does the actual idea matter?
Like do you care more about the actual person?
It depends what you're after.
For me it's all about the people.
I mean,
the idea has got to have a,
it's got to have a couple of legs important.
To me it's got to make common sense.
Okay.
And I've got a picture,
a lot of people buying it.
If I can picture,
a lot of people buy a nuance.
A lot of that stuff on for TV is nuance products because it's curious why would
have never thought of that.
And it's good for TV,
but it's not good for my pocketbook.
So if I see something that makes common sense,
it doesn't have to be unique.
I mean,
pork power,
barbecue sauce,
how many uh,
sauces are out there.
I've never even checked it.
I wouldn't want to,
cause I feel like a fool putting money in it.
Okay.
But I had something unique.
I had the guy that looked at the park okay.
And they were great hustlers.
The great hustlers,
you know,
smart guys,
great hustlers.
So for me,
I always pick out the entrepreneurs and the times,
I haven't,
the Times I've been swayed to pick the business cause it seems amazing.
I've lost money every time.
It's always when I just,
and you know what I do in my head when I'm sitting there,
when I'm,
when I'm equivocating which isn't that much like me,
I'm usually in or out within before they open their mouth based on what they
look like and how they act under pressure with the cameras zooming and how they
hold.
I kind of already deciding at least I know when I'm out.
Okay.
Um,
but I have to say that,
uh,
I don't know what I was saying.
What's your second question?
I lost my train of thought.
Yeah.
You were talking about what kind of makes it great entrepreneur always pay.
My conclusion there is,
I always pick the person over the business.
But your second question is that
what do you do?
Like when you are your own worst enemy,
kind of like when you doubt.
I am good advice on that.
Okay.
Because that is the real enemy in building any business of building any success
for yourself.
I really believe you are the enemy can,
you could look,
can blame this and this and this,
but how does,
how does a guy like a Branson do what he did?
I mean,
how does he do and nobody else built this giant airline.
How do people do it?
You know?
You know what I think?
I think the battle is won inside your own head.
One or loss inside your own head.
For me,
I had a huge advantage because I came into the adult world.
Pissed.
Okay.
Not all of my parents.
I had spoken glowing terms.
I was happy with that,
but I was such a horrific student in school that the kids made fun of me.
I couldn't read.
My idea of hell on earth was being made to read out loud and have to go the the
and everybody laughing.
Okay?
So when I got out of that Goddamn school house,
it was like a jail house from me.
I came out with vengeance and a need to prove I wasn't stupid.
Do you know how that's got me through the thick and thin,
the insecurity of thing,
and maybe I am stupid.
I still feel that way on a bad day.
But as a result of that,
I share this with you if it's helpful to anybody here.
I learned to develop a tape of my own because my old tape was this.
I would go into a situation,
not raise my hand.
I mean me speaking up,
even on shark time,
very hard for me to do,
to be heard.
You notice I don't talk as much because I'm like,
if they showed all the tapes for an hour and a half,
you'd see me say,
ah hmm.
All right.
But what I learned to do for myself is to,
when I start doing the,
Oh my God,
I should've come here.
Gosh,
they don't like me.
Oh my God.
All the self talk.
We all do it.
Whatever your thing is,
and it's usually from childhood,
some bullshit that went on there that formed you.
Right?
When I started doing that,
now I have a new tape.
It's not that new.
I've been doing now for 30 years and it goes like this.
I sit there and I go,
Hey,
wait a minute,
I have just as much right to be here as that asshole.
And I psych myself up.
I get really loud and says,
you know what,
this don't nobody who says you can't get your hand on the money like everybody
else would have anything in life that you really want to desire it go as far as
you.
When I get myself really steamed up and I always land the same place,
which is,
well fuck you.
And then I raised my hand.
Hey,
okay.
But that's self battle within.
It is so important within myself because when I feel like that Alice and
wonderland going down the rabbit holes,
whatever that famous line is,
it's on,
I'm shrinking.
Was that wizard of Oz and melting,
whatever the hell it is.
Okay.
But you know that feeling of going down.
Oh shrinking.
You know the minute that starts now I'm very good at bringing out of the person.
Right to the front.
You know?
And I'm going to prove that I'm swearing all the time.
I got to prove it.
It doesn't mean I don't feel,
I'm not some time,
but I've really kicked in.
I'm,
I'm a pretty fast forward on that now.
You know,
that's it.
[inaudible] and another one little thing for the women in the room,
sometimes on municipalization.
I just say to myself,
what would a man do?
And you know what?
Men are much more apt to speak up,
demand more as for the big arrays,
blah,
blah.
Then a woman would,
they really are.
I know,
cause I've hired thousands of people,
fire thousands of people.
I've worked with thousands of people.
I'm old,
I know this stuff.
Okay.
And I will often say to myself,
what would a man do?
And I'll say,
wait,
I'm not going to like understand the other side better than I understand my
side,
which is like me,
empathy.
I understand.
No,
I got to take care of me or to,
Hey,
let me tell you what I want.
That's what a man says.
Hey,
let me tell you what I want with a woman.
It's like,
you know what?
I was thinking that.
Okay.
Yeah.
Little different.
Different style.
Yeah.
As long as you get there.
Yes sir.
With the plaid shirt on that his mattress and that was all the rage when I was
17.
Yeah.
Not Take a time machine to come here.
Hello?
Yeah.
Does that bleed by the way?
That mattress?
Um,
you mean I don't sleep with this but no,
no.
When we used to wash a mattress it would bleed and that was cool.
Got It.
Oh yes.
Doesn't bleed out and thanks.
Okay.
Who would know by now?
I guess I would,
my question is more along the lines of persistence.
So what's your take on if you're,
if you're trying,
if you're fighting a battle right now and you know,
you,
it kind of looks like you're going to lose,
but you still have the impetus to persist.
Um,
what my device do you have on?
Well,
that's a hard one because it depends so much on your own good judgment.
Okay.
Most often,
uh,
it's far better to play your hand out because you don't want to leave without
the end of the story in my book.
In other words,
you want to play it out and see if he could bring him to the finish line.
Okay.
That being said,
sometimes you're hitting your head against the wall against a wall that doesn't
believe you.
It's never going to believe in,
it's never going to buy in in the first place.
And then I changed the wall and I use the same persistence to hit against a
different wall.
Very often a situation where you're an employee.
I could've been amazing as a sales clerk at my job at Schweitzer's department
store selling those granny gals.
Oh,
you're amazing barber.
You can sell those granny gowns,
but I was never going to run Schweitzer's department store no matter how good I
was.
You know what I mean?
It was owned by the Schweitzer's.
So I think you have to push push until your dignity is whole and you think,
well,
nobody could have done it any harder.
But I think you also have to know when you don't have a shot and move on and
spend your God given talents on somebody where it fits or something where it
fits so you can get stuck without moving on if you too much that way.
No vacillated answer.
I think I'll make that the last one cause I think we're over time.
Is that your God calling?
[inaudible] let's have a show of hands
on how many people love this guy's hair.
Well,
it is nice.
Okay.
You have a shampoo.